Kentucky man accused of shooting his
roommate for eating The house's last hot
pocket has been charged with felony
assault I wonder if he just came home if
he just opened up the freezer saw the
Hot Pocket was gone got his gun and shot
his roommate or was it more like a I'm
thinking about having a Hot Pocket I
think we have one left and the guy's
like oh no I ate that and then it was
like boom the man arrested for shooting
his roommate in the butt was 64 years
old wow so shooting your roommate in the
butt is a young man's game if I had a
roommate and I ate the last hot pocket
and he came with a gun I would have to
think like this isn't happening like I'm
not gonna die over a Hot Pocket shooting
your roommate over eating the last hot
pocket is the Kentucky state flag they
live for that sheer this guy's gonna be
the mayor when he gets out of prison